we filed this lawsuit not just because
of what happened there but because of
the kind of power that Google has is
this huge tech monopoly to interfere in
our public discourse interfere and what
people are seeing when they're going and
looking using their search engine and
really how they can impact our fair
elections we're doing this on YouTube
YouTube is owned by Google you're suing
Google yes what's going on they've got
too much power they've got too much
power I think the the short story is
after the first debate as well as the
second debate but after the first debate
I was the most googled candidate of the
night this is what we were obviously
hoping for as a campaign had prepared in
advance gotten our Google ads ready and
approved and ready to rock and roll when
all of a sudden mysteriously right at
the peak of that time where people were
paying attention our account was was
suspended yeah so you couldn't roll ads
could people weren't seeing the ads that
we wanted them to see was the bottom
line
we weren't really given any clear
explanations the answers we got were
very different from person to person to
person and then once that peak period
passed our account was magically
reinstated and to this day we still have
not gotten any kind of meaningful or
even an attempt to provide a
satisfactory explanation for it which
just points to the need for change we
filed this lawsuit not just because of
what happened there but because of the
kind of power that Google has is this
huge tech monopoly to interfere in our
public discourse interfere and what
people are seeing when they're going and
looking using their search engine and
really how they can impact our fair
elections yeah how do you decide when
that moment is that you want government
intervention because you know this is
where I lean a little more libertarian
and I think people on both sides of this
can take totally moral responsible
well-thought-out positions but there's
like just that spot where it's like okay
now we have to make a move yeah it's at
that point where we are now I think as a
country where people regardless of your
political ideologies or how you were
using these platforms are in a position
where our freedom of speech is
threatened and you have such a big tech
monopoly with the power to provide undue
undue influence both through their
algorithms as well as suppressing
people's freedom of speech and their
accounts even as Google has said
themselves when they are in compliance
with their terms noose agreements so
even though you're a congresswoman and a
Democratic presidential candidate you've
contacted them and if you just heard
nothing back from them
yeah I mean there was a that surprising
as well there was a huge delay and then
when we got responses again different
response from different people that
obviously our question was what happened
how do we fix it so we get our account
back up plain and simple yeah and that
simple question wasn't answered and so
really our lawsuit is is making that
point that if this can be done to me as
a member of Congress running for the
highest office in the land that means it
can be done to anyone running for any
office anywhere in the country it can be
done to any individual in this country
what do you think they're actually up to
like do you think that Google actually
has a political ideology or that they're
getting pressure from either other
candidates or the DNC H we know has done
some shady stuff and we're going to talk
about the debates and just to say some
of these things are listed in our
lawsuit of how in the past you've had
Google executives and people who are
very high up in their chain of command
talking about how they can use Google to
impact or influence the election who
they want to win the election so you
know again this goes down to where do we
draw that line we have antitrust laws in
place for a reason to protect consumers
and that's where I come from is we need
to be able to protect the rights and
freedoms of the American people and when
you've got an entity a private
corporation that becomes so powerful
that they have that ability to shift
things or influence things in their
direction for whatever their interests
or goals are to the detriment of the
consumer I think that's where government
should have a role to come in and again
advocate for the consumer so there's a
pretty obvious
through line to Google potentially
censoring you or whatever it is that
they're doing and the real disconnect
that I see between the conversation
online and mainstream because if you
look at the online conversation I would
say you and Andrew yang are basically
sort of the two hot candidates and the
one the ones more than anything else
that libertarians kind of like you and
left these kind of like you and there's
this really interesting mix of things
going on but if you listen to the
mainstream you know well now you're not
in the in the latest debate so what do
you account for with that is that just
purely just tech that says this connect
is also what we're seeing with people on
the ground who are you know coming out
to campaign events town hall meetings
who are engaging in our process we're
seeing that same thing that you're
talking about online being reflected and
in real life where with a broad spectrum
of ideologies of people who are coming
to my campaign who are supporting my
candidacy because we're about unifying
the country because we love our country
yeah we have care for each other as
fellow Americans respect each other and
understand that by bringing our diverse
ideas together and standing united we
can do great things for our country it's
interesting that you just said we love
our country because I mentioned this in
the green room but I had Glenn back in
here a couple days ago and he said he
didn't even know that you were coming on
because this has happened the last day
or so but what he said was I disagree
with Tulsi on almost everything but it's
very obvious that she loves this country
and I think one of the things that's
happening for sort of mainstream
liberals let's say not progressive which
sort of old-school liberals and then
pretty much everyone on the right is
there watching the candidates the
Democratic candidates and there's this
sense that they don't really love the
country like they really think it's so
fundamentally broken or wrong or
historically awful or some version of
that but that doesn't come across with
you my love for our country so it's
motivated you know these major decisions
that I've made with what I want to do
with my life you know 9/11 was a pivotal
moment for me I had already just even
when I was much
younger I decided that I wanted to
pursue a path of service somehow in my
life but it was it was that attack on
our country and our people on 9/11 that
really shifted the course of my life and
you know I chose to enlist in the Army
National Guard because of that because I
wanted to go after those terrorists who
had attacked us on that day and took
those thousands of lives something that
I and so many others in this country
continued to remember as we approach the
anniversary of 9/11 here in just a few
days yeah so speaking of that so I
wasn't planning on going there but since
we're only four days away from the 9/11
anniversary would you ever ever imagine
that the sort of level of discourse and
the way that we seem to be fraying and
that the sides are you know running off
in different directions and the middle
keeps getting whittled away do you think
you could have envisioned that way back
when probably not you know especially
the unity that we saw in this country
after that attack took place it was a
beautiful thing and I think it really
represented what we're talking about
that as different as our ideas may be as
different as our backgrounds and stories
may be as diverse as our country is we
stand united as fellow Americans and we
are there for each other especially
during those darkest of moments but
increasingly we are seeing these divides
further tearing us apart as a people and
a loss of that remembrance of what that
unity is and why it's so important that
common ground that we stand on as fellow
Americans and how integral that is to
our identity how do you think we get
back to that because there's a feeling
that we should get back to it yeah I'm
kind of everyone's kind of like oh I'm
tired of the hate I'm tired of you know
destroying everybody and the rest of it
but no one's sort of leading us there
yet I think that's the problem is is we
have people in positions of power and
influence and yes politicians people in
the mainstream media and others who
profit or benefit in some way shape or
form off of further deepening these
divides and Fanning those flames of
hate that really undermine who we are as
a country and I think I think the vast
majority of people in this country are
sick and tired of it they're sick and
tired of the gridlock in Congress sick
and tired of the hyper partisanship and
those the the divisive rhetoric that so
often comes out of Washington and are
looking for leadership that will bring
us together if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell